[Applause]
[Music]
let us not forget that we are involved
and upstairs we want our freedom and be
wanted now when you see something that
is not right of fair justice you have to
do something
[Music]
one person with a dream with the vision
to change things when people talk about
you what you want them to say
[Music]
well this is such a great honor for me
to be in this room with you to have this
conversation I can't tell you what it
means to me to have this opportunity you
represent something so precious to so
many of us and I just wanted to start by
thanking you for that for your
willingness to wrap your arms around
people like me and to make me think that
it's possible to do difficult things
important things and I just want to
start by asking you to talk a little bit
about that experience of growing up in
rural Alabama and the Black Belt of
America and how that cultivated this
spirit that shaped your life in your
vision you used to have to pick cotton
on your family's farm well I used to
fuss as a young child of a complaint why
this father and my mother was a boy so
anything we can do she's down to his
hard work well what are we going to do
we have to make a living but I was
hoping and almost praying what I day
when people wouldn't have to work so
hard in a hot Sun she was hoping also
the thing would be better much better
first as other people and for my family
my mother she was always thinking ahead
did we get up early and go and pick as
much time as we could we would get more
money cause she knew the car would be
heavier could a deal we'll be on it so
when it was weighed money will be
increased yeah your mother sounds really
strategic my dear mother one day she
came across a little newspaper in
downtown short that says something about
a school in Nashville Tennessee
the blanks student could attend she
encouraged you to apply for that even
though that meant you'd be leaving the
house should be leaving the farm you
would not be contributing that that
extra labor well I was prepared in
willing to go to try to do what mine
what was called during better yeah to
get at at education but in the beginning
I wanted to attend Troy State you wanted
to to desegregate for his state submit
him application my high school
transcript I never heard away from the
school so I wrote a letter to dr. King I
didn't hear my mother my father any my
sisters and brothers any my teachers I
told him I needed himself he wrote me
back there sent me around sure very hard
bus ticket and invited me to come to
Montgomery to meet with him and I can
never ever forget it you knew about dr.
King even before the boycott you had
heard his sermon the Apostle Paul
preaches to American Christians it's the
speech he gives to all the people in
Montgomery four days after Rosa Parks
has been arrested at the end of his
speech he says one day they're gonna
tell a story about a group of people in
Montgomery Alabama and then he says of
black people who stood up for their
rights and when they stood for the
rights the whole world changed and you
had an immediate response to that call
to action the message really appealed to
me and it was sort of social gospel
message yeah I wanted to do what I could
to make things better cuz when you see
something that is not right a fair
adjust you have to send something yeah
you have to do something it's like a
fine burning up in your bone and you
cannot be silenced right
my mother was said to me boy don't get
in trouble don't get in trouble or you
can get hurt you can get to you dr. King
and Rosa Parks
eating Nixon and others that have read
about the nighttime and later meant it's
fine we're gonna get in what I call the
trouble necessary trouble and I've been
getting in trouble
it was sense the city and the free to
ride you went to Nashville and again the
work of learning non-violence when did
non-violence become an essential part of
your worldview and the theology and the
activism that you wanted to create
growing up wanted to be a minister yeah
I felt that what dr. King was saying
yeah in his speeches was in keeping with
the teaching of Jesus so I readily
accepted this idea yeah
non-violence the philosophy and their
discipline yeah uh nonviolent we would
talk to respected dignity in the words
of every human being yeah and never give
up on anyone or try to reach them yeah
the kindness will hope faith and love
yeah so you may beat me you may arrest
me into in jail but I'm not going to
engaged involves nobody respect you as a
human being and I'm wondering whether
that is what gave you the courage to
endure some of that brutality because a
lot of people talk about non-violence
they talk about the theology of love but
when you're on a bus in Anniston Alabama
or in Montgomery Alabama as you've been
surrounded by that mob and surrounded by
that hate surrounded by people who you
know were prepared to do violent things
it's a different dynamic
you know accepted that dr. King told us
to to love yeah
listen keep it with that Christian faith
good love everybody and never hate he
was the hate is too heavy a burden to
bear but it seems like you were
strategic to you all fought a lot about
when and where to go someplace it wasn't
just oh here's an opportunity here let's
just do it we just didn't jump up one
day and decided that we would go to
Selma
we check places out when I was a
possibility of leadership or creating a
rival organization of whether he has
students people will prepare to get out
of work and organized and that's what we
did we did everything that we could to
bring attention to the situation that
was not good for people and that we
could organize people there were
religious leaders teachers and lawyers
and others in these communities and
neighborhoods but a good time to the
training yeah and acceptance
non-violence the philosophy as a way of
living as we align that you become
prepare it was a lot of rigorous
training to be prepared to be in those
very stressful situations and and
maintain that commitment to non-violence
and I don't think people appreciate how
much work went into preparing people for
that well it was something that we
became committed to yeah that had to go
to role plan social drama potamia that
to of meeting someone knocking someone
down someone's blowing smoke in your
face and calling y'all check obeying
training people hi to be disciplined and
I given up on the Freedom Rides and me
in 1961 when I was 21 years old leave in
Washington do you see for the first time
they're gone their freedom running I
thought we were going to die as a matter
of fact I thought I saw death mmm what I
believe God Almighty kept me here for a
reason it's a powerful powerful
testimony I see a picture of you and and
your head is bloodied this willingness
to get back on a bus to do it again and
they interviewed you
after some of that sit-ins and what was
interesting to me about the way you
talked about it is you were very clear
you said we're not just trying to do
this for the black people in Nashville
we're trying to do this for everybody
because they may not realize it yet but
what they're doing is wrong and I
wouldn't be the Christian that I claim
to be I wouldn't be the good person I
claim to be if I didn't try to help them
get past this wrong thing they're doing
I think people want Redemption our faith
tradition we understand the power of
redemption we preach about it and we
understand that there has to be
confession there has to be repentance
but collectively as a society we haven't
really embraced that in this country we
haven't really wanted to acknowledge the
legacy of slavery and the history of
lynching and segregation people want to
skip over the apology part and you still
see these Confederate flags and these
symbols of resistance seems to be part
of what is so urgent right now is that
we get people to have the courage to say
you know this was wrong
and we have to reject that but you have
seen that redemption in ways that I
think has been so extraordinary a few
short years ago one of the members of
the Klan who beat me and beat my see
Tinley in a little town called Rock Hill
South Carolina left us lying in a pool
of blood many years later one member of
the Klan and his son came to my office
in Washington and you said I've been a
member of the Klan and one of the people
that beat you and left you bloody I want
to apologize his song start crying in
East or crown he came up with his song
the hook me the hook and I and I saw
this just went through other time it's
the power yeah well the way of love yeah
forgiven this yeah
to admit it yeah and some change
yeah and move on it does seem to me that
if we can show people that on the other
side of repentance on the other side of
confession on the other side of
acknowledgment there's something
beautiful like what you experienced with
that clan member then maybe they'll find
their courage to stand up and talk about
the wrongfulness of these things
there have been curious how you would
talk about what you learned from your
time with Rosa Parks and dr. King what
they taught you what they left you with
that has allowed you to do the work
you've done that there's something about
these individuals touch me they reach me
if it hadn't been for eating Nixon or
Rosa Parks wonders the King jr. Reverend
Abernathy and so many others I don't
know what would have happened to me I
could have been lost the [ __ ] wonder
the King junior to sit me roundtrip
Greyhound bus ticket and invited me to
come to Montgomery to meet with him my
First Baptist Church it's impossible
yeah impossible for poor therefore the
boy yeah to dream that one day you would
meet one of the King jr. I remember so
well he said for you the boy from Troy
are you John Lewis and I said dr. King
I'm John Robert Lewis and he called me
what from Troy High is the boy from Troy
Dillon and sometimes you went said thing
it's like John do you see a preach you
know it was there yes doctor came when
I'm taking a shower so no one can hear
me and he was lame I think we nee when
he was assassinated when he died
something died and all of us
if he had deal you know there was a
young man yeah yeah maybe I country
would be much better and the world
community would be better we were
talking earlier about those critical
moments 1964 the passage of the Civil
Rights Act the Voting Rights Act in 1965
and it seems like our focus was on
ending the violations of Rights and less
on remedying that this long history of
violations and what it would take to
repair all the damage that has been done
and today I'm thinking you know in
addition to no longer denying vibe
people the right to vote
maybe these states should have done
something reparation alive done
something remedial they should have said
you know what we're gonna let black
people we're gonna automatically
register every black person to vote the
vote is most powerful nonviolent
instrument or two that we have in a
Democratic Society
maybe must make it easy and simple
Whoopie per to music you know the people
who get a very long yes people who took
the beatings yes and suffered yeah I'm
so we have a right to know what is the
new food we eat
yes what is in the water to drink or the
air we breathe you were the youngest
speaker at the march on Washington in
1963 and you were very eloquent and you
were very compelling I had worked on the
speech with some of the staffers of the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee but I was determined to
inspire young people another generation
when I looked out and saw this sea of
humanity that's the air to myself this I
said I must go for it
I tell you came together and we worked
all of us very hard on getting the
Lord's cry on the mall that day but it
was so well into the president President
Kennedy invited us down to the White
House after the March is over and he
stood in the door the Oval Office
greeting
and beaming like a proud father and he
can send to each one of us you did a
good job you did a good job when you got
to dr. King he said you did a good job
then you had a dream there was my last
I'm seeing President Kennedy's well I
might him yeah there was something about
the man yeah there was so inspired yeah
yeah you talked about how he and Robert
Kennedy were an influence to get into
politics I know you first ran in the 70s
and then you ran again and the A's I'm
curious what motivated you to make that
shift my soul in politics that you could
be a force for good so I was motivated
to to run for office and people start
encouraging you should run for something
and I made a decision I don't think I
changed that much no I think I'm the
same same person except what I want to
say and I most water do what I want to
do I think you have to be a force for
good yeah there's my people yeah to
encourage people I was so moved when you
organize the protests around gun
violence and I'm wondering how you think
we should be teaching people what it
means to be hopeful how do you think
about communicating that to to both your
colleagues in the Congress and and
another generation of leaders who may
get down we get knocked down but you get
up and you keep moving you keep personal
that was part of the civil rights
movement yeah a new day a better day
we're gonna come but we have to have
that day come it couldn't be quiet
yeah can be silent we have to be engaged
in Queen the way I don't know where you
think there are strategies that we've
abandoned that we need to pick back up
to confront the issues that we're
looking at today I think there's so many
tactics and techniques
that we sort of abandoned that we need
to go back and pick up these techniques
and taxes and use them we need to teach
people especially our young people you
know we taught great school students and
high school students and college
students to learn to embrace the
philosophy and the discipline of non
dollars after engage in nonviolent
direct action we need it now more than
ever before I think you brought into our
political culture this spirit of
activism the spirit of of strategic
protest a willingness to even
occasionally be disruptive you haven't
attended all of the inaugurations of
presidents when you felt like there were
issues around the legitimacy of those
elections and I see a new generation of
politicians that seem to embrace some
aspects of that and I'm wondering
whether you think that the kind of
modeling you've done is going to be part
of your legacy that's important to you
as a politician there's so impressed
that this new breed of young men and
young women that are coming into elected
position it's not just at the national
level but also at the local that I think
we now more than ever before need men
and women of conscience if George's
especially on a federal level but also
at a state and local level to say we got
to get the men we got to make up yeah
people don't have 100 years to make up
yeah we need to do it and do it now
you've become somebody who's had such an
impact on the world when people talk
about you 50 years from now hundred
years from now what you want them to say
how you want to be thought of how you
want to be talked about my hope
I don't think of how much to say about
it but it means
he tried to create a better society
that'll have inter delivery and free
people effort to save people and move
people to a different and better sense
of humanity I have met people who worked
with you there's so many that whose
names have never really been known but I
encountered them every now and then cuz
they get to live in Alabama and I I talk
about a man I met who was in a church I
was giving a talk and he was in the back
is in a wheelchair and he was staring at
me the whole time I was giving this talk
and he had this Stern almost angry look
on his face and when I finished my top
people came up they were very nice and
appropriate but that old man older black
men in the wheelchair just kept staring
and then they finally wheels himself to
the front and when he came up to me he
said do you know what you were doing and
I just stood there and then he asked me
can he said do you know what you're
doing and I mumbled something I don't
remember what I said and then he asked
me one last time he said do you know
what you're doing if this time will tell
you what you're doing he said you're
beating the drum for justice you keep
beating the drum for justice and I was
so moved I was also relieved I just
didn't know what was about to happen but
then he said come here come here come
here
and he pulled me by my jacket and he
pulled me down close to me and he turned
his head and he said you see this scar I
have right here behind my writer he's I
got that scar in Greene County Alabama
in 1963 working with Ct Vivian then he
turned his head he said you see this cut
down here I got that in Philadelphia
Mississippi trying to register people to
vote and then he said you see this
bruise that's my dog spot I got that in
Birmingham Alabama in 1965 during the
Children's Crusade and then he said
people look at me they think I'm some
old man covered with cuts and bruises
and scars but I'm gonna tell you
something is that these are not my cuts
these are not my bruises these are not
my scars he said these are my medals of
Honor and I am sitting here sitting next
to you and I still see the scars and I
know that there are the bruises and I
know that there are the cuts and yet you
are still talking about love and
redemption and justice and inspiring
people like
me and I just want you to know I don't
think there's an American living that is
more honored more representative of the
great values of this nation of the hope
of this nation than you and I just I
just cannot tell you how thrilled and
privileged I am to have this opportunity
and to have this opportunity to share
and I want you to know I am gonna keep
fighting a lot of us gonna keep fighting
and you have caused us to believe that
we cannot rest until justice comes and I
want to thank you for that wish you will
absolutely my friend absolutely bless
you okay yeah bless you brother thank
you thank you thank you
[Music]